nights we ask how can we make sure the
recovery from the pandemic is green
how should we confront the challenge of
the climate after covert
a very good evening well today we
learned that the uk's climate assembly
wants the recovery from coronavirus to
be green
polluting new cars it thinks should be
banned in as little as 10 years time
and people should be encouraged to eat
much less dairy
and meat the question is though whether
we're ready
to make those sacrifices well tonight on
climate after covert a green recovery
they're going to be exploring the
climate choices facing us
and the potential solutions which
deliver green growth with me
to do that is our very special panel
they're
assembled from right across the world
we'll meet them in a moment or two
and also with us a virtual international
audience truly international
who'll be questioning them and letting
us know
their views oh yes they will uh hello
and good evening to you all give us a
wave
well lots of work for them tonight but
uh first let's get a stock take on the
current state
of climate change from a country where
it's pretty much impossible
to ignore it's very clear effects we're
talking about iceland it lies close to
the arctic circle
and about 11 of the country is covered
by glaciers
well those glaciers are predicted to
lose up to 35 percent of their present
volume
within half a century or so now if
melted they alone
would raise global sea levels by one
centimeter
well that's the future challenge but in
the present one the country's health has
been
relatively unaffected by coronavirus
with only about one percent of the
population infected so far
but the impact on iceland's economy has
been very different with visitor numbers
down
80 percent this year skies adam parsons
reports from one of the country's
most endangered locations
welcome to vatna yokel ice cap it is a
hard place to reach but when you get
here
it is captivating on this island of ice
and fire the ice here is discolored by
volcanic ash sprinkled over it by an
eruption a decade ago
the glacier can survive that but what
might kill it
is us as the world has warmed so the ice
in vatnayoko has melted faster and
faster
over the past 90 years this whole
glacier
has receded by five miles it's never
goodmanson has been studying it for
decades it's uh devastating actually
it's uh surprising to see how fast this
happens
around him this glacier is eroding
before our eyes
a very obvious victim of climate change
water is gushing into this huge lagoon
it was only formed
86 years ago but from here you can see
how the glacier
is falling icebergs that have broken
away
and this
an ice cave collapsing as we watched
as long as the world is getting warmer
the glaciers will retreat
in a century or two iceland could have
very little
ice this new giant lake the ice the
cliffs where the glacier one sword
they're all a warning about the
fragility of our ecosystem
the question is whether the world is
paying attention
[Music]
well clearly a stunning place in adam
parsons is live on that glacier in
iceland right now and joins me now so as
i say there adam a stunning place but a
stunning
rate of loss of ice as well
yeah that is right the sun is about to
set uh here over the yokola it is
an extraordinary otherworldly uh
scene i have to say this area has that
sense of brutality of nature but
also of fragility because this glacier
is melting
at a pretty extraordinary rate look at
those cliffs
up there they're about 300 meters tall
that's the same height as london's
tallest building the shard
a century ago the ice went right up to
the top of them and if you look into the
distance
you can see what five miles away six
miles away
the glacier used to extend all that way
and yet it has
melted over those hundred years why well
because the world has got hotter and
when
ice uh heats up then it melts in just
the time i've been talking to you less
than a minute
it's estimated that about seven million
litres of ice have melted from this
glacier alone and that feels to me like
a pretty stark warning to the world
astonishing what a sight thank you adam
well from the freezer to the fire quite
literally our chief correspondent
stuart ramsey is tonight in para in
brazil where they're fighting fires in
the amazon rainforest once again stewart
yet more evidence of the of the human
effects
on climate change
that's the rainforest behind me i'm just
going to step out of the way
it's on fire it's as simple as that
there's no other way of putting it
um we're surrounded by fires we're just
going to keep focusing on these
occasionally the trees will just
uh go alight we've been in here this
region and inside the forest today
and the light yesterday as well with the
fire brigade who are trying to control
the fires
here there are just five of them and
they are
they've got literally hundreds of
thousands of hectares to look after
what they're in doing at the moment
they're still in there is uh trying to
build a fire
uh wall to stop the spread of the flames
into the trees but uh it's it's it's a
difficult battle this
fire has been going on uh for a week or
so as we come down from this
uh you'll see one of the reasons why
these fires start
everything you see in front of me is is
cattle land it's
massive blaze that was here that's all
burnt as you can see
unless we've seen many times over the
years but very bad last year
and they think this year could be even
worse it spreads
into the forest the farmer who's been
here with his father for over 20 years
says that
it's simply the climate it is hot hot
hot
it doesn't rain it's been at least three
months and basically
climate change he says is the reason for
all of this
stupid thank you very much indeed stuart
ramsey there in the rainforest in brazil
well as we've just seen two examples of
there
the impact of climate change is being
felt in so many countries right
across the planet and our audience
tonight is also international we've got
people
from india russia iceland zambia
nigeria ghana and the united states as
well as the united kingdom
and ireland so audience i want to get
you working i've got a
first question for you and it's this one
about priorities
which issue do you think should take
precedence
right now coronavirus or the climate
now hands up let's choose one of them
hands up if you believe one hand please
if you believe that coronavirus is the
pressing priority
[Music]
quarter mid 25 maybe maybe 30
something like that think it's
coronavirus so
we can assume given you've all you'll
want to take part here that
the rest of you think it should be
climate change well it's not just
a virtual audience that we've been
questioning about this the sky news poll
carried out by hugo for us asked people
to tell us
what they think the government's
priorities
should be well these are some of the
results and it's almost
a mirror image a flip of what our
virtual audience
have said 67 said the coronavirus
pandemic and just 15 said climate change
the rest said neither or that they
weren't entirely sure now those fine is
going to be of course of much interest
to our panel let me
introduce them formally then they are
claire o'neil uh
minister for energy and clean growth
until last year when
she was asked to run the next big global
meeting
to address climate change cop 26 uh a
nomination that was later
withdrawn we've got sally mulhock is one
of the world's
most prominent climate scientists and
director of the international center
for climate change and developments
joined by audrey gallagher served on the
advisory board to the climate assembly
and his deputy chief executive of energy
uk our quartet is completed with bjorn
longboard
the author of the skeptical
environmentalist uh he doesn't argue
that climate change isn't happening but
says it isn't an
apocalyptic threat well let's hear from
you all uh first off then index claire
o'neill this
this issue of priorities the difference
between our audience
and and the polling but um on the
polling
uh two-thirds of people think we really
should be dealing with
coronavirus as a priority
well you know honestly i'm not that
surprised by that derma because you know
we have had
nightly hourly news for the last six
months of the coronavirus threat
you know it has been you've been
reporting it constantly
we it's something that everyone has been
talking about we've had the whole
economy shut down
and we haven't had anything like the
same coverage of the climate crisis and
the fact that we currently have you know
the highest level of
state uh fires burning in california we
have cities around the developing world
running out of water
and we have record temperatures now
right across the globe
and i also think there is a bit of a
problem with this that you know climate
change
can feel a bit separated from us in
terms of space and time it's that
classic kind of tragedy of the commons
but you know the climate layer
is 60 miles thick that's it and we've
been conducting an
uncontrolled chemical experiment with
that layer collectively
for the last hundred years that isn't
going to end very well unless we start
to do something about it so
i'm not surprised by that polling i
think we need to all work and i really
commend you actually for doing this
program
to make people realize that this this
this change is happening
but that it isn't apocalyptic you know
this is the world's potentially the
world's biggest economic opportunity
climate recovery
uh is both something that's absolutely
necessary and something will completely
transform the way that we live and do
business
and we need to get on with it we're
going to be hearing a lot from you all
during the course of this program sally
mull hugh bender
your thoughts on those findings on on
the public's view
well i think it's uh natural that people
are concerned about the public health
crisis
that is actually affecting them their
families and people are
in fact dying immediately on the other
hand climate change is a longer term
problem but it is a big big big
problem and speaking from dhaka in
bangladesh i can tell you
right now part of the country is flooded
it's one of the biggest floods we've had
in
decades and just a couple of months ago
we had a super cyclone
that attacked our post in the middle of
a pandemic so
the crisis aren't an either or there are
multiple crises that all have to be
dealt with at the same time biolog what
are your thoughts so
i mean do you think perhaps maybe you do
that the public are right in
that ordering of priorities
well i i would be more likely to agree
with saleem
sorry salimo so fundamentally
we don't prioritize problems we
prioritize solutions
and we need to realize they're great
covet solutions
where we can spend little money and do
an amazing amount of saving people's
lives we should definitely do those
they're
pretty poor covet solutions where we
spend lots of resources and save almost
no one
we should definitely not be doing those
and it's the same with climate
there's some great climate solutions and
we should be doing those there's some
really bad
ineffective climate solutions we
shouldn't be doing those so it's not
about prioritizing
climate versus covet it's about making
sure we do the
smart cove solutions and the smart
climate solutions
and don't do all the dumb ones okay
we're going to be discussing a lot about
those possible solutions during the
course
of the hour and more but let me ask you
then
audrey gallagher it's about the
government's attention i suppose in
terms of priorities
what are your thoughts i think
obviously the government's going to have
to deal with the immediate effects of
the pandemic and
you know we've got a public health
crisis on our hands
and they really need to get that under
control um
but after that the recovery from covert
it doesn't
we're not talking about a binary choice
here we can do both and in fact you
mentioned the climate
assembly they have said quite clearly
that in the recovery of
uh and coming out of we've got to ensure
that we
at what we do is going to contribute
towards meeting the next zero targets
and we're already here in the government
talking about building back better
and you know we're going to have a clean
green recovery and i really want to see
that happen i think it's possible
um and that's what we should be aiming
for but of course you know
we we need to deal with this public
health crisis first okay your opening
thoughts thank you very much indeed for
them let's get the opening question then
uh from our audience it comes from
dominic panaya from
london uh very good evening to you
dominic identify yourself
there you are please ask your question
put your question to the panel
um given that governments across the
world have proved how quickly they can
deal with a global emergency
with no expense spared will they now do
the same
for the so-called climate emergency um
very good and uh interesting question uh
sullivan sami
salimo you you come in first on this
this is about i suppose
will and application if the climate
crisis is is real why aren't governments
acting
with such speed and the amount of money
that they are over covered
thank you very much dermot please call
me saleem it's easier to pronounce
um yes i think even
even though the coronavirus is not
related to climate change there is a
very very
i think message uh important message
that is a very common message that we
are seeing
play out in dealing with the coronavirus
situation which is
leaders who listen to their scientists
and their epidemiologists
and took action at the right time ended
up
saving lives and the leaders and we
don't need to name them we know who they
are
who did not do that who refused to
listen to the science
have ended up being responsible for
debts
by the thousands indeed hundreds of
thousands
of their own citizens and that is a
lesson that we need to apply to the
climate change crisis as much as well
because the scientists are telling us
what to do leaders
some are taking the actions required and
i'll mention the prime minister of new
zealand as a good example
and some and mr trump of the united
states
is an example aren't and that is going
to play out to
everybody's detriment going forward so
listen to the scientists
do actions as quickly as possible and i
agree with bjorn
if they are cost effective do them
quickly that that's really what we
need to be doing thank you well okay
well let's bring in beyond then
and your thoughts on that question
address it directly if you will from
dominic pena there and he's saying well
look look at the amount of money
governments all around the world are
spending on coronavirus they've
correctly identified it as a crisis and
the fact with climate change they've
been calling it a crisis for years
but not acting in uh
at the same speed not spending the same
amount of money
yeah so dominic you're absolutely right
we're spending an enormous amount of
money remember it's mostly money we
don't have and we probably actually
can't afford
uh so i i think we should be very wary
of whether we're actually going to spend
them well
just for corona but the real issue of
course is how do we then
get governments to spend money smartly
for climate
and that has to be about making sure
that we don't just spend
lots and lots of resources and stuff
that looks good that makes everyone feel
like oh we're doing something
one great example of how we're wasting
resources is when we subsidize for
instance electric cars
that is an incredibly ineffective way to
mostly pay
rich people to drive around these
virtuous cars but cut
very very little co2 on the other hand
if we could get
a lot of countries to switch at least
first from coal
to gas we could dramatically drive down
carbon emissions at very low cost so
it's about making sure that we spend
resources in places where we can cut
lots of co2 at low cost rather than
doing the opposite
okay what the question is directly
asking though claire o'neil
is i suppose our government's really
just pre
paying lip service to climate change
because we've seen how fast
and how effectively they can act when
they see
people dying well the short answer to
dominic's great question is no they will
not
turn the taps on and spend the money and
they'll they won't do that for three
reasons one
is uh you know as bjorn said that money
is very short
and the politics are that if you see an
nhs in the uk overwhelmed with patients
that's incredibly bad for your electoral
prospects if you don't stop
uh climate emissions going up people
don't really notice and so the
you know the short-termism of the
government cycle the average prime
minister globally is in place for about
four years
means that this just simply is not a
priority
and i spent you know several years as a
minister i bought in the uk's net zero
legislation
um we had wonderful support actually
particularly from prime minister theresa
may
but you know we we were in a place for
many years where it was not taken
particularly seriously by governments
and i'll just point out that you
mentioned german that i was the
president designate of the cop
process uh this is the act this is the
annual climate gathering the thing that
led to the paris agreement
uh that's been running was set up in
1992
in rio and since those uh enormously
expensive
huge conferences have happening
emissions have gone up
by about 40 so there's an awful lot of
intergovernmental talking
and there's not a lot of action is it
all gloom and doom there will know
because
the question assumes that it's only
governments that tackle
stuff like this and i've got a logo up
behind i don't know if you can see it
i've taken on a new job
at the world business council for
sustainable development because while
governments
are doing some amazing things and
setting out that zero targets
the world's biggest corporations who
understand that if they don't start
investing and don't start taking this
seriously
there will be a huge problem are
starting to move
and that kind of expertise is why you're
with us it's why you're all with us sir
audrey
on this issue of of government's will
and action is it the fact that
coronavirus just hit us with such
speed and that's in a way climate change
is creeping up on us
so clearly we've seen that there had to
be a response to that
i think though as we we mentioned before
it does represent a good opportunity to
know and
try and take some action ensure that we
can address climate change
the government's going to have to go out
and borrow lots and lots of money for
the recovery from covert
let's make sure that any fiscal stimulus
packages that are going in places
bjorn said we're doing it in a
sustainable way we're investing in
technology and sectors where there's a
real future and we can
we can tackle climate change this is
offered as an opportunity
i think people have also seen that they
can live differently
um because the whole thing about about
climate change
yet we are tackling climate change of
course we need government intervention
we need
plans from them um we need a clear
policy framework in order to bring
forward investment
but there's also going to have to be a
significant change to people's behavior
and i think that's something that we
just haven't really started the
conversation with people around that
people don't really understand what this
might mean for them
and i think we have to do that as well
as just rely on government this is not
something that governments can deliver
claire mentioned bringing in businesses
but we need to take the public with us
as well
everybody's going to have to change
significantly to get this done
okay well let's get on thank you all for
for that but let's uh get on to this uh
this climate assembly because it's so
one thing to accept that climate change
is still despite coronavirus the most
pressing issue facing the world
it's quite another perhaps to agree on
what to do about it well as we've heard
the uk climate assembly which reported
today
want some significant changes let's take
you through just some of its suggestions
nearly
four in five of the climate assembly
members 79
nearly 80 percent agreed that the
recovery from covet should be
green and these are some of the actions
to get there 80 percent of them
recommended that taxes for flying should
increase as people fly more often
or further frequent flyers should be
penalized they also say
people voluntarily should reduce their
meat
and dairy consumption buy up to 40
percent so
are people prepared to make those kind
of sacrifices and many others our sky
news poll for this program
suggests well it depends
the most popular policy to aid a green
recovery was continued
encouragement for people to work from
home with 64
nearly two-thirds in favor versus just
20
opposed now that idea of encouraging
people to eat less dairy and meat
was the least popular that we tested
with just 33 percent a third
in favor 53 were opposed to that
suggestion
and there was little confidence in uk
political leaders
over climate change when we asked who
people thought
cared the most out of boris johnson kia
starman nicola sturgeon
and the leader of the lib dems ed davey
35
said none of the above well let's bring
in
uh audience right here and i want to ask
you what do you
make of that polar let's get your hands
up again would you like to see action
for example to encourage people to eat
less meat and
dairy produce would you like to see that
actively discouraged by governments
and uh nearly all of you just stay with
us and let me ask you a slightly uh
different version of that are you making
efforts yourselves right now
to to do that to change your diets
okay so more than half but a few you
then want it what a bit of encouragement
from your governments and on the subject
of encouraging better behavior versus
enforcing it
is our next question this comes from
danny hurley
in clitherow hello there danny please
put your point to our panel
hi everyone uh given the government's
draconian approach to tackling the
pandemic
would a more authoritarian solution to
reducing greenhouse gas emissions
be more effective than a liberal one
well well well danny very good question
let's see what our panelists make of
this
bjorn lomborg well we've seen we've
heard
just in the last few days in in the uk
about covid marshall's laws to stop
people gathering in groups above six
it's the law people will be penalized
people will be fined who knows
people may go to jail what about when it
comes to the climate then we've got
covered marshals couldn't we have
climate change marshals telling people
to recycle and turn their engines off
well i mean i think first of all there's
actually been quite a number of people
suggesting this
uh but ethically i can't imagine that
anyone would really support this
you can't say that you want to have a
democracy but then for some things you
actually want to be authoritarian
i think we need to recognize that this
is something where we have to convince
people to do this on the merits of the
proposals which of course again goes
back to saying
look you really only need an
authoritarian government if you're going
to
carry through policies that people
wouldn't otherwise support
that's why we need to find solutions
that people will actually support
rather than going in the other direction
and say we should go authoritarian i
think that's a terrible argument
what do you think audrey gallagher yeah
i thought
i think it would be an absolute disaster
if
if we try to impose this on people
because you're talking about
you know up until now we've we've done a
big job of decarbonizing the power
supply in the country
but you don't notice when you switch the
light on that you're using greener
electricity
the changes that are going to be
required are going to be quite
significant about you as you've outlined
how you
how much you travel what you're allowing
what you eat
that can't be imposed on people and i
think what the climate assembly has
shown is that if you
educate people if you give them the
information then they can start making
some of the trade-offs and make some of
the choices
and that's going to be really really
important i think probably the most
important thing about
all of this um is fairness so
you know there is an issue about it's
going to be difficult to reach net zero
but how we do it not if we do it is
going to be just as important
because you know this is coming at a
significant a significant impact on
people's lives
potentially at significant costs and we
need to make sure that that's born
properly
and we need to take people with us in
order to do that because it is a huge
undertaking
i know you know what i'm going to go
back to to danny and say you asked the
question and
what by asking it was it's the fact that
you actually would like to see
governments legislate perhaps put into
law criminalize
a behavior that affects the climate
no i understand that authoritarian's a
very strong word
and i agree with what the panelists have
said but if i was to define the liberal
approach to being
the paris agreements um i think it was
emily o'neil who said that
since the parish agreement was
introduced that the missions have
increased 40
so the reason why that's failed in my
opinion is because the paris agreement
is
uh it relies on naturally determined
contributions
so in effect countries can choose their
own targets they can set their own
targets
so that to me proves that targets can be
missed they are being missed
so banning certain uses of fossil fuels
would surely
be the most effective way to do it and
to do it by deadline would
allow a smoother economic transition as
well well great question thank you very
much indeed for that danny
and a great answer which you know what
uh has got all
our panelists i don't know if you can
all see each other but all nodding
in agreement uh that perhaps it's got to
be carrot
and not stick uh thank you very much
today for that contribution
uh danny from cleveroad now we want to
discuss
now another and it flows directly from
the issue
of coronavirus and uh the the
the steps that are being taken to try to
deal with it we've got uh miranda
collette who lives in jersey who who
wants to ask um
a very specific question don't you
miranda put it to us please
okay i'm concerned about the plastic
waste that's accumulating through ppe
and disposable masks and gloves um the
pandemic seems to have set the
anti-plastic movement back a few years
is there anyone dealing with this and
how are ppe
items recycled yeah and just while i'm
with you miranda i mean
you're on jersey as i say you must see
the effects of plastic waste on the
shores every day
we certainly do yeah um luckily some of
us regularly pick up all the plastic
around our beaches
good for you okay well let me put that
point to claire o'neil and i mean there
is a huge amount we're talking about
billions of individual items single-use
items of ppe
being discarded on a daily basis around
the world and we hear
today in the united kingdom and ambition
for instance to carry out something like
10 million coronavirus tests per day
they presumably will be disposable
that's an awful lot more plastic what
are your thoughts clara neil
well i think it's a great question a
couple of years ago we when we had
actually i think skye did a lot of
coverage on this when we had the great
blue
blue blue ocean series we got really
concerned about the long-term impact of
plastic waste and we made
huge progress actually both in the uk
and elsewhere you know and i've been
very struck by the fact that
you see a lot of discarded masks you can
no longer use reusable coffee cups
uh we know we all carry those around to
try and do our bit and and i think this
is a fabulous question because it shows
the kind of unintended consequences of
some of these decisions
the good news is a lot of this stuff is
incinerated i mean i know there are
questions about air quality but when
it's used in hospital settings it tends
to be incinerated
and i think we have to encourage people
to actually start you start again as
citizens using their own reusable
uh things and can i can you bear with it
if i just go back i wanted to go back to
danny's question just for 10 seconds
having brought in a number of laws in
the climate space
um you can't be authoritarian as a
government but you can
lead and things like the banning of
fossil fuel vehicles on our roads which
uh audrey's climate assembly thought was
a really good thing
that was actually the most controversial
thing that we did in the last few years
and so i think governments have a
massive role to play
in leading on this and it's been rather
depressing that
none of the government leaders or none
of my old mates
around the cabinet table i think i've
met have ever mentioned publicly
the issue of plastic waste having made
such a focus of it so i do think we need
governments to recognize this problem
and come up with some solutions this is
a simple solution
just want a quick thought from saleem i
mean again you must see in
in bangladesh the the effects of plastic
pollution in the oceans
on a daily basis and uh this coronavirus
pandemic is only making it worse but is
it a necessary evil
well definitely we see this and but
interestingly you know bangladesh is one
of the first countries to bla
ban plastic bags used in in dhaka city
we don't
use plastic bags here anymore because
it's been banned and everybody's now
gone to using other kinds of bags
instead so
it is possible to get people to change
and and change behavior
but if i can also address the previous
question uh for a minute which is that
one of the things that we can definitely
look at and i'll pick the example
that bjorn gave of in his view a wrong
kind of subsidy for electric vehicles
in my view an even even bigger wrong
subsidy
is for the fossil fuel companies these
companies are getting huge subsidies
from their own exchequers and that to me
is not just wrong
that's criminal that should not be
allowed how the hell can we give
subsidies to the polluters that is
absolutely unacceptable
in this day and age uh
you got an awful lot i don't know if you
can see our audience there but they're
certainly agreeing with you uh
many many of them i think well the vast
majority of them are clapping
along there with that well listen uh got
a lot to get through and we've had a
real sense there of the
difficult choices facing societies and
governments right now
and one society perhaps more significant
in this than
anywhere else has to make its own choice
about the future on november the third
we know where we're going don't we the
united states debate about climate
is starkly split between president trump
and joe biden the challenger mr biden
is partly influenced by more radical
voices on the
left of his party the democrats and one
of them prospective congressman jamal
bowman
told me his country could take on the
virus
and rescue the climate at the same time
we're living through the greatest crisis
in our nation's history since
the great depression uh we're also
living through
a period similar to the spanish flu as
well as the civil rights movement
as well as economic and education
catastrophe
and climate catastrophe so i believe we
can
walk and chew gum at the same time
listen before the pandemic before the
coronavirus
climate change was ravaging communities
throughout the world but what about
questions such as the financial
realities of dealing
with covid the billions upon billions
ultimately trillions of dollars that
have been spent whoever's in power
in the united states next january the
cupboard's going to be bare
isn't the money just not going to be
there for this transition
to a truly green economy when we have
our values rooted in the right place
we invest where we need to invest when
we wanted to put a man on the moon we
were able to do that
when we wanted to bail out the big banks
in 2008
we were able to do that the real
question is do we have the resources
do we have the human capital and the
resources
to not just get out of this pandemic but
to build a nation in the world that
works for everyone
and the answer is yes we have millions
upon millions
of men women and children ready willing
and able
uh to get to work what would you say to
those developing countries to say
listen this is all well and good coming
from the mighty united states which
built its economy on the back of fossil
fuels and now you're saying you know you
won't do trade
deals with us or whatever sanctions
would be applied
if we go down the same route we have to
follow it the green way and it's going
to take us longer and be more expensive
this is about us working in
collaboration with them
being clear on what the needs are and
then taking
a bottom up strategy uh similar to what
we're doing here
in our district uh in the northeast
bronx and westchester
there are communities historically
neglected communities
that haven't been a part of this
democratic
economic climate conversation and we're
going to pull them in
have let them have a seat at the table
and make sure their voices and their
needs
are centered joe biden isn't as radical
as you are
when it comes to the climate he's a
centrist he's cautious he's going to be
hearing a lot of voices if he wins
those votes in the rust belt saying
listen we don't want to make wind
turbines we just want to get back to the
steel industry
or whatever it is he doesn't share your
vision
well joe biden is not king joe biden he
is elected by the people of this country
and he has already begun to move uh
to the left on the issue of climate
change i believe he's
committed one trillion dollars over the
next 10 years
to fight the battle of climate change a
lot more needs to be done there
but he has already moved to the left and
what about the other potential outcome
what if it's a second term
for donald trump who has in the past
said that he thinks climate change
is a hoax what happens then you know
it's interesting there's been a recent
study
uh by the financial industry on the
impact of climate change
to financial markets uh donald trump uh
commissioned that study
so although he says publicly that he
doesn't believe in
climate change in edison it's a hoax the
fact that that study was commissioned
and now we're looking at the impact
on financial markets leads me to believe
that donald trump the republican party
and those who may deny the climate
catastrophe publicly
privately they understand the
ramifications of it and
are looking at it all from a financial
markets perspective
so again if trump wins we will continue
to fight and do the work that we
currently do
uh no matter how much trump tries to
change this nation into a fascist nation
uh we will not let him and the people in
the streets
will not let him and we will demand what
needs to be done for climate and every
other issue of justice
uh in our nation well my interview with
jamal bowman there and
we clearly know which side of the
political landscape he sits but
what about our audience now i suspect i
already know the answer to this question
i'm going to
put to you because i saw the look on
your faces there when we discussed
donald trump and uh the applause you
just gave mr bowman there at the end of
the interview but let me ask you
put up your hands if you think donald
trump's re-election would be the best
thing for the world's climate hands up
if you think donald trump's re-election
would be the best thing for the world's
climate right well okay
um well what's that two two percent well
two that's four percent fifty of you
obviously two
three perhaps some of you some with your
heads in your hands so
that would be a negative vote if you
could well let's ask our panelists there
very small proportion thinking that
donald trump is serious when it comes to
his protestations
about taking climate change seriously of
course as i mentioned with jamal bowman
there he's also
called it a hoax so audrey gallagher
would it be
an enormous setback for the fight
against climate change if
president trump is re-elected
so um i was personally really
disappointed when i seen that america
had pulled out the paris agreement
notwithstanding what we've
spoken about the the the paris agreement
on
um on climate um on the on the panel
already
um we you know this is a global issue
and it's a real
concern that the world's biggest economy
isn't on board with tackling it because
that you know
it needs to be tackled globally um i
think you know there's there's no doubt
that there are
i should you know our government
probably worries about um
the competition of industrial
competitiveness
um but i think if we do this properly if
you bring investment forward in a
sensible way we can actually create jobs
you can re-skill people you can find new
jobs that
and and we can develop technology we
could we could be a world leader and we
have been a world leader on things like
offshore wind
and how quickly we've brought the costs
down to that um
and developed new technologies and i can
see the same happening again with other
um emerging technology and i think
that's what we need to
we really need to focus on um loads of
countries out there are coming up with
their own plans about you know
the european union has got a green deal
i do think we'll get some challenges
around about you know we can't just
offshore some of these emissions
there's a lot of work to be done on um
you know
carbon border taxes and stuff like that
to make sure that we don't do that
um but there's no you know there's no
option not to do nothing here
and and that's why it's you know i'm
pleased that our country has taken a
bold step
to put it to it put the net zero target
in place by
2050 somebody has to take some
leadership beyond longbow
what are your thoughts would it be a
disaster for the fight against climate
change if you
get a president re-elected who thinks
that things like wind turbines cause
cancer that fracking is a great thing
well look fundamentally we don't need
donald trump's uh
climate policies i think all of us in in
the panel agree on that
uh but the real issue and i think that's
what we need to sort of step back and
you also
ask that question to bowman is to recall
that most of the rich world is actually
a fairly small part
of the emissions in the 21st century so
if the u.s
went carbon neutral tomorrow which of
course won't happen
and stayed carbon neutral for the rest
of the century
it would if you put it into the u.n
climate models reduce temperature by the
end of the century by
0.2 degrees or a little less than that
it would probably not even be measurable
the most part of the emissions that
we're going to see in the 21st century
is about three-quarters are going to
come from china
india africa latin america the world's
poor countries right now and they of
course want to get richer
they are not likely to be willing to
spend
many trillions of dollars and i think
that tells us
what matters is not so much who wins
although i would like biden to win
but it's much much more about making
sure that we pick the right
targets that is invest dramatically more
in green energy r d into zero carbon
energy technologies
because if we can make green energy
cheaper than fossil fuels
everyone will switch not just rich
well-meaning countries
but also everyone in latin america and
africa
in china and in india so i think we
should stop focusing so much on on the
us
and remember the real challenge is to
get the world's poor it's a global
challenge
of course it is and we've got a global
audience and uh what 54 of us
participating if you leave me out i'm
the moderator in this discussion 50 on
our panel and uh we've identified
the one person who thinks that donald
trump would be a world leader when it
comes to climate change mahan
there you are why do you think that
well if we phrase the question as
would it be better to leave climate
change in the hands of the private
sector
or the government i think that's a
question
for particularly audrey or claire who
recently
tweeted about something like this so i'd
like to know their opinions
on that please we will find that very
soon you've done your research
that's why you're there thank you very
much indeed for that mahan we want to
talk about jobs though as well and i
will put those
those points to clear and audrey because
one of the questions
for both those aspiring to become u.s
president
and around governments like the uk's is
whether new
green jobs can quickly replace those
lost
during the course of this awful pandemic
well here in the uk alone our sky news
job tracker
shows that at least 129 000 jobs have
been lost
since the start of the pandemic more
than 30
000 of them lost in the aviation sector
alone well now compare that
with the finding of a new report by the
ippr think tank now it suggests that low
carbon energy efficient social home
building
could generate something like 560
000 jobs maybe more than that it says in
fact the think tank claims that
more than 1.6 million jobs could be
created through investing in low-carbon
projects
and programs over the next decade well
let's get a question on that subject uh
and it comes from andrew lound from
birmingham of course formerly
the workshop of the uk workshop of the
world knows an awful lot about
manufacturing i suspect
andrew good to talk to you what is your
question
hey good evening yeah with japan and
sweden
actively supporting hydrogen and fuel
cell technology
how can the public be sure that the true
innovation
such as hydrogen and fuel cell
technology is going to be actually
supported in the uk
especially the midlands rather than
simply being blocked and frustrated
uh by government and and the vested
interests
okay well comparing with japan and
sweden claire o'neil
um does the uk take these new
technologies that their potential
for jobs and of course reduction of co2
emissions does it take it seriously
yes massively so i mean we have about
250 000 people working directly in the
low-carbon economy in the uk now and
that number's growing
very rapidly every year and those jobs
are everywhere from
aberdeen to cornwall that's a bigger
sector than the aviation sector we just
don't talk about it
and andrew you should be really proud of
the fact that um thanks to
some amazing work done uh by the former
government but
still the conservative government but
the former one uh we actually set up
uh some incredible innovation around
fuel cell batteries because we don't
just want to assemble cars in the uk
we want to make the batteries that
actually go into the electric cars
and there was quarter of a billion
pounds invested in a thing called the
faraday
challenge and also in hydrogen there are
lots and lots of efforts
uh going on to actually try and drop the
cost of hydrogen but look frankly
what we need a bit more of is a bit more
public private cooperation in this space
just to go back to that that question
the private sector can't do this alone
you've got to have regulation you've got
to have things like
in fact i think carbon border taxes are
a great way of dealing with some of the
really high emitting economies who then
want to dump their steel
on some of the countries that are really
trying to clean up their act but you
know the private sector can see
innovation and can move so much more
quickly in many cases
than governments and you need these
partnerships but yes
this green stuff this clean growth
uh was at the forefront of the uk's
industrial strategy
and that work does continue and by the
way birmingham is a fantastic place
for the innovation that that sector
needs yeah but but salim as
we've discussed this is a global problem
and it needs a global response and on
these
technologies is there a danger that the
developing world
gets left out doesn't it need the
developed world the uk's the united
states the eu's and the rest of them
to invest not just in their own
countries but in
countries like bangladesh as well
yes indeed and and but i think you know
the
the old paradigm is now history where we
in the developing world used to think
these were burdens on us
it isn't true anymore we are now also
forging ahead
on renewable energy and let me cite my
country's example
we have the biggest household energy
solar energy system in the world about 5
million households
providing solar energy to 20 million
people
who weren't getting electricity before
that they were burning
kerosene at in the night and and that
has
it enhanced the quality of life of very
very poor people living all over the
country in rural bangladesh
so technological leaps and developments
are not confined to the developed world
and they don't need to be brought from
there
to us on the other hand we can teach you
how to cope with the impacts of climate
change because we know how to do that
and you don't john lombok do you have
faith at these new technologies are out
there
and do and will provide solutions
oh look there are lots of solutions and
some of those as salim also mentioned
uh you know uh solar panels for very
poor people who don't have any access
wonderful thing but it's not what's
going to lift you out of poverty and of
course
at the same time as bangladesh has has
gotten a lot of solar panels
they've also seen their uh emissions
keep increasing they have
increased 15-fold over the last 50 years
because
it is what drives development and so
what we
really need is to make sure that the
rich world which is thinking of spending
lots and lots of resources don't spend
it on
subsidizing existing inefficient
technology
but invested in investing in new and
research generated uh solutions so
basically make sure
we innovate new technologies that
everyone will want to do
so biden for instance he's promised a
lot of stuff and a lot of it is probably
unaffordable
but he's actually promised to increase
spending
to 75 billion dollars a year that would
be a five-fold increase of what the
world is currently doing
on research and development into sierra
carbon energy technologies
that would be a fantastic opportunity
and that is what could help
not only the rich world to deal with
this but also everyone else
because obviously you know both people
in bangladesh and denmark and everywhere
else
would be using this yeah let me ask you
let's just focus again on the uk audrey
gallagher i mean
part of the reason it seems that the uk
is having such a round with the
eu over its negotiations over a trade
deal is that it wants the freedom
to invest particularly in tech
companies does that give you a sign
that's and of course
technological solutions we're talking
about is that a sign to you that the uk
government
does take this seriously i think
the government definitely takes it
seriously claire's outlined some of the
measures that have been put in place
just recently we've seen the industrial
clusters around
um hydrogen five of them across the
whole country so
there's definitely stuff happening and
if i can i mentioned about
the the offshore wind sector that has
has
we've reduced emissions in the power
generation sector by about
70 in the last 10 years a massive
success story
the only reason we were able to do that
is because
good policies get put in place backed up
by really strong environmental
protections
it gave certainty investors came forward
made that investment
developed the technology brought the
cost down massively i think like the
first round at auctions it was 150
pounds it's now less than 40.
so huge benefits so if we can take the
lessons from that
and apply them then hopefully we can
obtain the competitive advantage there
but also reduce emissions
make things cheaper for people and i
would just say as well i know we're
talking about technology
but actually really simple things like
making our homes more energy efficient
will create jobs up and down the country
it will massively reduce emissions
people will live in warmer homes they'll
be healthier
they'll save money so as well as looking
at the bright shiny stuff we need
government to be looking at how we can
do
the basics well quite a lot of applause
there
and thank you very much indeed where's
the time gone we've got our final
question and this one comes from
elizabeth baba yemi from fall cook and
it's all about the these warm words
these aspirations so making sure
that they're put into action put put
your question to the panel elizabeth
very good to see you
thank you dammit do we need a new
protocol order
to safeguard the world a cross-continent
panel of youths
adults and experts to evaluate the
impact on climate to covet and
the way forward great question elizabeth
well we've been talking about the
climate assembly
uh in the uk that has come forward with
uh
some possible solutions over the last
few months let me put this to you
then selene first of all do we need i
suppose
a new body a new global body to think
about
solutions and perhaps enforce them as
well
well we already have a global body and
we have the paris agreement and we
aren't seeing a lot of enforcement going
on there i believe in a more
bottom-up approach if you like working
from the bottom up from people who are
already
thinking about the problem and young
people in particular all over the world
in fact the youth in bangladesh are
extremely
engaged on this issue and are doing many
many things and connecting with youth
around the world as well
so to me a bottom-up citizen-led
approach
which would also take into account
people taking action themselves and also
holding their own leaders to account to
make sure they lose yeah they have the
right kind of leaders and then the right
kind of leaders take the right kind of
decisions
that's the point let me bring in audrey
because that is the point isn't it we
saw you nodding along there
of course bottom-up whole population
citizens
need to be involved but do they also
need to make sure
be allowed to make sure that what they
recommend happens
yeah so already um there's uh
letters i've got the prime minister the
the base select committee is going to be
doing uh
doing an inquiry and looking at the
recommendations that have come out with
the climate assembly and already
particularly because of the pace of
change the technology that's coming
forward there's calls for it to be
repeated
um and i think we definitely need to do
that we we have to ensure that this gets
done
the the committee on climate change does
a brilliant job in our country
um but you know there is a question
about how do you replicate that and get
it done on a global level unfortunately
i don't have the answer then i'm i'm
really keen of
particularly in the audience
right to be so clear neil you were you
were nodding along there with the idea
of a global climate
assembly well i love the idea of the
panel of youth
experts and adults but we already have a
way to hold governments to account in
democratic countries and that's through
the ballot box and it is you know
quite alarming that uh certainly in the
uk at the last election climate even
though people
really care about this you know what
what mattered in the last election
was brexit and secondly use our green
dollars you know companies around the
world
want to be making this change want to
invest in this change but too many of us
are not exercising our
thoughts in the way that we make make
choices the way that we spend money
um and so i think i love the idea of
having this citizens assembly i can't
tell you how
how amazingly good the work is that was
done you know audrey's team
it was super pragmatic it was really
common sense it was the first time we've
actually been able to get a really good
representative view
on what people think is think is right
um but also
you know we don't vote about this so we
tend to think this is important
and then we all go back and start you
know worrying about other things so for
goodness sake let's exercise that power
we've got
um there are lots of solutions out there
as has been said this people are taking
this seriously it's very hard to enforce
these things internationally
but we can vote beyond lombok um would
it just
just end up being uh just another
talking shop but
it isn't there the un and the existing
global bodies aren't they adequate
well certainly we we gotta be
honest and say we've made lots and lots
of promises the last 30 years
and we can see almost no impact so the
un environment
agency uh the u.n environment program
last year told us that despite you know
trillions of dollars spent
lots of people making lots of arguments
we can't actually see the difference in
temperature or in emission trajectories
so really we should ask ourselves should
we go on
doing what has not worked for the last
30 years or do we need to find another
way and as claire also point out another
way that can actually get a majority
at the ballot box and i think we need to
do that by making sure we do something
that's effective that is reasonably
cheap so you can actually get people to
vote for it and keep voting for it
and something that'll actually fix
climate change so samuel said yes
absolutely
let's get rid of fossil fuel subsidies
let's also make sure that we spend
resources on an innovation so that we
can actually get the green revolution
going
and then let's make sure that we also
deal with the all the other problems
like covet
as we started out talking about well
thank you all very much indeed for that
on the panel well we're talking about
getting
people involved well we've got our
audience there of course and we let's uh
involve you one more time in this uh
television
version of our debate and uh let's put
elizabeth's question
back to you i want to ask you do you
agree that a global panel
something like the uk climate assembly
but on a global scale don't know how
many people would be involved in it
is one way forward a global climate
assembly
hands up if you support an idea like
that
i'm seeing some of you may some of you
making up your mind started about oh
about three quarters now gone up to 80
90 percent i'd say that one other
question
on that issue then so you've got this
assembly
it's sitting it's deliberating it's
coming up with its suggestions it's
going to worry
the governments aren't going to act on
it do you think it should be given i
don't know how it would happen but just
we haven't got much time
it should be given some enforcement
powers hands up if you think it should
again three three quarters slightly less
well and there we must end it thank you
very much indeed to all our wonderful
audience and our
wonderful thoughtful and erudite panel
may i say thank you
all and that was climate after covert
a green recovery
and the debate's going to continue on
sky news digital platforms now we're
going to be putting more of your
questions plenty of them coming in
as well as more from our audience
they're staying with us to our panel you
can see that show
continue on the sky news website it's
also there
on our mobile app and indeed on our
youtube channel
as well and as part of that we're going
to be hearing in
just a moment or two from one of the
stars
a great comedian of the american version
of the office on his conversion
to the climate course
all i was doing was occasionally sending
out an angry tweet
you know i was what i call uh and what i
call a slacktivist
um and i knew that that wasn't going to
cut it